las condiciones climáticas serán
favorables este domingo para la
contención de los brazos incendios que
asolan desde la mitad de la semana al
sur de chile que han llevado la
aclaración del estado de catástrofe en
al menos tres regiones del país la
araucanía biobío y el núcleo aunque son
dos más las que comienzan a verse
afectadas por la expansión del fuego en
total ha habido 24 víctimas fatales
hasta el momento por los incendios
también más de 800 viviendas destruidas
entre ellas 20 establecimientos
educacionales según el último balance de
las autoridades el subsecretario de
interior Manuel monsalve también
informada de la detención de 10 personas
por su posible participación en el
origen de los incendios algo que será
perseguido penalmente con mucha dureza
advirtió mientras el presidente Gabriel
boric que suspendió sus vacaciones para
atender la emergencia visita de nuevo la
zona afectada está en el bío bío y
también ha estado ocupado en las últimas
horas coordinando la cooperación
internacional los primeros en prometer
ayuda fueron los vecinos
que comprometieron el envío de
brigadistas también de Estados Unidos ha
enviado ayuda económica y del otro lado
del Atlántico el presidente español
Pedro Sánchez anunciaba vía Twitter el
envío hoy mismo de un avión de la unidad
militar de emergencia con material
especializado para la lucha contra el
fuego algo alguien en el que el país
tiene mucha experiencia las autoridades
trabajan a contrarreloj porque a partir
de la próxima semana se producen
condiciones climáticas extremas que
podrían de nuevo favorecer la expansión
del